[Music]
your days of fighting for the so-called
greater good
are over
this is our chance
to control the truth the concepts
of right and wrong
for everyone for centuries to come
you're fighting to save an ideal that
doesn't exist
never did
you need to pick a side
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
no woman no crying
no woman no christ
[Music]
don't shed not to you
no woman no cry
good friends we have and good friends
we've lost
the way
in this great future
you can't forget your past
societies
[Applause]
is
[Applause]
[Applause]
i am queen of the most powerful nation
in the world
and my entire family
is
have i not given everything
when i wake up
wow
[Music]
have you given any thought
to where this ends
the table will never stop
you know this
no one
not even you
can kill everyone
[Music]
you ready john
[Music]
black adam
what have your powers ever given to you
nothing but heartache
i was a slave until i died
then i was reborn a god
my son sacrificed his life to save me
[Music]
in this world
they are
well i do
my vision has shown me the future
you have two choices you can be the
destroyer of this world
or you can be its savior
that's up to you
behind you
did he just catch a rocket
you know my fresh coat
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i know one thing
wherever we go
this family
[Music]
is our fortress
[Music]
i'm an idiot
it's showtime
i don't deserve these powers if i'm
being honest like what am i even
contributing
wow there's already a superhero with a
red suit with a lightning bolt on it
aquaman is literally huge and he's so
manly and batman is so cool and i'm
just me
[Music]
i feel like a fraud
it doesn't matter um anyway the wizard
gave me super powers
and then everybody got super powers was
everyone going
to fight crime okay
now everyone's kind of like doing their
own thing and i'm the only one trying to
keep it together
you understand i'm a pediatrician
right
come on
[Music]
of all the gods
this is very personal billy
[Music]
look i might not have as much experience
as you because i'm not super old like
you but i've seen all of the fast and
furious movies lady it's all about
family
family guys that was a signal
introducing the star of our show
his name is
[Music]
i don't know how we fight powers like
this
[Music]
you think i know how to fix this dude
but i really don't
can be worthy
let's give it a chance
now go fight for your family go fight
for the world
[Music]
i just threw a truck at a dragon i love
my life
[Music]
here's the thing
we're a team of thieves
then when you do this
you're bound to make enemies
sometimes those enemies come looking for
revenge
truth be
told we helped the wrong person steal
the wrong thing
we didn't mean to unleash the greatest
evil the world has ever known
but we're gonna fix it so how do we pull
that off
uh figure it out over a drink probably
best you need food give us a fighting
chance we're gonna need strength you got
this right i know you don't
we also need courage
magic
and you
what is that again it's an owl there
[Music]
be warned
there is evil here
i'm glad he's on our side
this one's dangerous
but whatever happens
we'll be ready
is it exactly that you bring to this i'm
a planner i make plans you've already
made plans so if the existing plan fails
i make a new plan so you make plans that
fail no he also plays the loot not
relevant
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
again
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
you don't
[Music]
how did you get
how have you been it's a long story
is this the room you grew up in uh it it
is but uh my my dorm room is very adult
right no of course
hey are these your drawings what no no
good
i missed you too
okay
so what are you doing here
i mean i
i thought i'd
never see you
again want to get out of here
[Music]
i'm
grounded
bummer
is spider-man grounded
um
i mean
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
you the only person i ever met
belonged in this guy
just remember you belong down here with
us too okay
[Music]
the commanding officer called you one of
the best pilots he's ever seen
it must be hard being a naval aviator
absolutely
[Music]
the whole world's looking different do
you ever think that you'd be in a
squadron with a colored aviator
lieutenant tom hudner jesse brown it's
good to meet you
we're taking a slight detour on the way
home say again
what are you going to find out about
your wingman cruising at 10 000 feet
lieutenant
put him in a little bit of trouble who
knows i might get a peek at who he
really is
north koreans came pouring over the 38th
parallel
our guys need help
and we're up
we knew this day might come
and it doesn't make it any easier
the most important thing is this
we bring everyone
home
mistakes get us killed
i can't tell you how many times people
have told me to give up quickly
die even
if i did i wouldn't be here
what do you want me to do just be my
wing man
the real battle in all of life
[Music]
being someone that people can count on
show off that was pretty good it's good
an evil is coming
that threatens our kingdom
our freedom
but we have a weapon
they are not prepared for
[Music]
my king the europeans wish to conquer us
they will not stop until the whole of
africa is theirs
we must fight back
for our people
[Applause]
some things
are worth fighting for
don't know
no kingdom in all of africa changed this
privilege
i offer you a choice
fight
or we die
you must kill your tears
[Music]
we are the homies
[Applause]
[Music]
once upon a time
you all lived together
then the wars came
and you ran off into your little corners
of the world
[Music]
now you're scared for your life
all you have to do
is pledge your
loyalty all kneel before king kano
[Music]
i will teach you to use your senses to
live not to die to be the best warrior
take your stance
let's protect earthrealm
this is my fight
good
time to die
against those with power
no one stands a chance
is it just me or is it getting a little
bit nippy out here
he's here
and there is nothing you can do
to stop him
[Music]
wait up wait up
what do you do with all this junk
keeps me busy
another long night of crime and violence
some say it's only a matter of time
before the city implodes
i think we're finished here come on beat
it
i found him
samaritan
samaritan died 25 years ago
that's what they say
you think you live across from a
superhero
do you have a therapist kid
good that is what you mean samaritan's
dead
i pick up garbage for a living about the
same thing
cleaned up the streets
you mind your business on my
mind are you okay
i'm cool
how strong are you
kind of struggling that once was things
start to fall apart when you stop caring
and i stopped carrying a long time ago
how come you hate who you are
for some people it's too late to change
the damage they've done
he's hiding something
i want him dead
really
[Music]
the things you bury tend to haunt you
why did you disappear
[Music]
hey old man
try this
hey look out the window
welcome to my party guys
[Music]
thank you so much for having us this is
my chance to reconnect with the girls
did mom shoot some please this little
bump right here that's you i still miss
her every day
what's that there's something crossing
up the head
keep the girls stay in the car okay just
stay in the car what happened yeah
okay what's he saying dearborn
i've never seen anything like this
multiple attacks
without eating its prey
lies don't do that
at least no lion i've ever seen
[Music]
go back to the calls
slow down
we're in his territory now
it's the law of the jungle
it's the only law that matters
i need you to trust me right now
i'm coming back
don't you move
okay
why do you want to hunt
because you all think that i can't
i saw a sign in the sky
i'm ready
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
there's something out there i'm coming
with
you can't i'm trying to protect you
protect me from what
[Music]
it's time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
it knows how to hunt i know how to
survive
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i can kill it
[Applause]
[Music]
deer creek international business
solutions how can i help you i am ready
well that's great ladybug ladybug your
new operational name oh i see what
you're doing ladybug's supposed to be
lucky
you don't have bad luck
really
my bad luck is biblical i'm not even
trying to kill people and someone dies
remember the suicidal bell boy you drove
him to the hospital hang in there buddy
and he didn't die okay the wedding
[Music]
johannesburg
it's time for some change do you want it
simple for your first job back it
doesn't get simpler
we need to find the person who took that
case
[Music]
that's too easy
[ __ ] what remember those two wackos from
the bolivia jobs the twins yeah sure
they're twins get off the train
i missed my stop something else going on
here hi
you don't remember me you look like
every white homeless man i've ever seen
really you don't remember me
he's a pack of dicks lady i'm sorry i'm
sorry i'm i'm working on it
get off at the next stop sounds so easy
when you say it one little prick from
this you know what happens yes your
blood congeals
i said yes
there's this soulless psychotic leader
with the largest criminal organization
on the planet shoved right inside
i don't see the white death letting any
of us off this train
we need to come up with a plan
[Music]
what's happening to your face maybe
there was a little head trauma
[Music]
i gotta get off this train
[Music]
sorry buddy
exclusively in movie theaters
[Music]
you